[Music]
i think that the biggest problem with
math is a branding issue where people
think that math is
rote boring and about memorization
if you ask me what math is i'll say math
is actually the
distilled heart of thinking
it's logic it's thinking about ways that
if something was true
then something else is always true and
as you learn how to assemble these
chains of logic you can use that skill
for anything
so actually my real goal is to help
build the world to be a more thinking
place
[Music]
the man in front of the class is no
ordinary math teacher this is so good
and the kids in the chairs are no
ordinary students p squared e
they are the u.s team for the
international math olympiad
the best high school math minds in the
country
my angle as a coach is actually a little
bit different from what some people
might expect
i actually don't optimize for whether or
not the team will win
in this particular competition that's
coming up and this is a conversation i
actually had with the executive director
of the mathematical association of
america
when i was picked to take this role as
coach the goal is to not only teach
skills that could be useful in this
contest
but to also show how the math that
they're working on could be used later
to do other things
and also to talk about some of the other
skills that one might need besides
mathematics
the biggest difference between a math
competition problem and a textbook
problem
is that in the textbook problem you were
supposed to already have been taught how
to solve it that's actually why it's a
textbook problem
whereas a math competition problem is
specifically selected based on the
ingenuity of the problem
and the hope that you won't know how to
solve it when you see it
and actually that's why i think
everybody benefits from playing with
math competition problems
they teach you how to invent new ways to
think
about challenges and the kinds of
challenges we face in this world today
are not textbook problems well right now
we're dealing with covid
if that was a textbook problem we'd be
done by now and so the real purpose of
everyone engaging in these math contest
problems
is so that people can get a chance to
exercise that creative muscle
when it comes to creating analytical
ideas
honestly the task of improving math
education is hard
i have the utmost respect for the people
who are working on this
all the time but if i could make a few
suggestions
i would actually suggest to focus on
having people spend more time
thinking about how they might come up
with an idea on how to solve a problem
as opposed to having students be used to
the idea that someone else is going to
show them what to do
and then they're just going to copy it
that's actually what i do in my own
teaching
i actually don't want to show students
what to do and have them copy
i want to bring them along to help them
also discover
the reason why you should multiply those
two numbers is because of something that
you came up with my favorite aspect of
being a coach
is the opportunity to see people who are
so much more talented than me
and to know that the future is bright
that gives me the optimism to
keep carrying forward in life
you